her heart is broken Lisa we all love you
Priscilla Presley remembers Lisa Marie
on a solemn Milestone what would have
been her 55th birthday now she is home
where she always belonged but my heart
is missing her love and for her late
daughter's birthday Priscilla tells E.T
in a statement my wish is to protect my
three grandchildren and keep our
families together our hearts are broken
and I am having to learn to live without
my only daughter she always knew she
wouldn't be here too long
childhood passes by with a glimpse of
her green eye she then grew a family of
her own Priscilla is now turning to her
oldest granddaughter Riley Keough but
it's not for Comfort a legal Showdown
looms over Lisa Marie's trust it is huge
you know to live under the light of
someone as big as Elvis it's a big
responsibility in the wake of her
mother's death Riley was named as the
sole trustee but Priscilla's calling the
will invalid in legal docks obtained by
E.T Priscilla claims Lisa Marie's
signature on a 2016 amendment to her
trust could have been forged she also
says the paperwork was never delivered
to her and misspelled her name all the
children
have to have their own life obviously
it's a struggle for them because it's a
huge name to carry according to Joel
weinshanker managing partner at Elvis
Presley Enterprises Riley was prepped to
take over the enormous Legacy although
Riley is a movie star she's a you know
an award-winning director she had always
had an interest and always known that
one day uh she would be in charge
obviously it's much much much sooner
than we would ever hoped for uh but on
Lisa's birthday we just want to think
about you know what Lisa would have
wanted and that's what's best for Elvis
and you know she never had it down her
mind but that's Riley so what's at stake
here Lisa Marie was 16 million dollars
in debt and there's a new report
claiming she had 35 million in life
insurance and of course there's
Graceland which brings in 110 million
dollars a year you know the best years
of Graceland the best years are ahead of
us uh even with all of this tragedy and
what we need to do is we need to honor
you know the ones who honor Elvis and
that was always always you know his
daughter Lisa is absolutely 100 of mine
always has been mine Graceland always
will be and when it's no longer mine it
would be my children's
I'm gonna read something Riley wrote
thank you for showing me that love is
the only thing that matters in this life
I hope I can love my daughter the way
you love to me the way you loved my
brother my sisters
thank you for giving me strength my
heart my empathy my courage my sense of
humor my manners my temper my wildness
my tenacity
I'm a product of your heart
[Music]